so like Asda said she said something
about being a kind of odd bird in this
lab and I'm definitely in that category
as well the reason is I don't study
machines I don't study algorithms I
study people everything I'm gonna tell
you about today was joint work with Mary
Gray she's another researcher in
Microsoft Research New England we
recently wrote a book you can get on
Amazon that's the cover
it's called ghost work I'm gonna tell
you just a little bit about it today so
Mary is an anthropologist for those of
you that don't know what that means that
means she studies people like I do but
I'm a computer scientist and the
questions we wanted to answer in this
book are who are the crowd workers why
do they do crowd work and what are the
pros and cons to them and in any
crowdsourcing site you know there's a
requester who puts the tasks on the
platform
there's the platform and there's the
crowd and the crowd looks like a black
box they're behind the API you can't
really see them you can't really get to
them they look well invisible so what
mary did was she circumvented this API
and met these workers face-to-face
interviewed them in their living rooms
at cafes around the world in India in
the United States and I'm a computer
scientist this just this makes me
nervous just thinking about it right
like I don't even want like wow I'm
scared right now anyway so she did that
about 200 times she interviewed about
200 people and what she had this great
interview data that's very rich stuff
and so what I would do is I would be a
requester on one of these platforms and
I would put up a task that would measure
her findings on a larger scale and we're
gonna see an example of that in a few
minutes
the general idea was to open the black
box of the crowd just to give you guys a
sense of what we did we did almost two
years of field work where Mary and her
team were you know interviewing people
around India the United States about 200
interviews about 2,000 surveys about
dozens of behavioral experiments with
thousands of respondents each and I'm
gonna tell you about some of this stuff
a give an example of some of this in the
next few slides so I'm going to tell you
about how we took some interview data
and then measured it at a bigger scale
so I'm going to give you a few quotes
quotes from Mary's interviews so Mary
interviewed Sanjeev he was a 22 year old
student and she meant she interviewed
him with along with his college buddy
and he said if I'm working on a hit a
task on Mechanical Turk is a popular
crowdsourcing site it's called a hit if
I am working and I find a good hit then
I call him and I tell him about it
and then Farid was a devout Muslim in
his late 20s
he lived in Hyderabad he said anyone who
sees work posted and calls and tells
everyone there's no fixed timing
whosoever is alert season informs
everyone and in this way everyone helps
everyone else he's talking about a
hundred fifty friends on Facebook so
what's going on here in both of these
quotes one person found a good job to do
on Mechanical Turk call their friends to
let them know about it so the workers
are talking they're communicating and
they're collaborating so right here
already you know this notion of crowd
when I think of crowd I think of like
independent individuals that notion is
kind of broken right they're talking
there's a network there so we wanted to
scale this finding up and see how do we
map this network so what we did in a
very one sentence description is we
built a Facebook light kind of app for
Mechanical Turk workers to use where
they can anonymously report who they
talk to and we paid them to use it and
III go I'll save the details for later
and we basically ran this experiment for
about two weeks where workers couldn't
again anonymously report who they talk
to you we got 10,000 respondents and
later work show that that was roughly a
census of all the workers you could
possibly hope to get in about a two-week
period and we got 1,300 workers added at
least one edge between them and this is
what the graph the network looked like
and if I was sitting in the audience I'd
be like Sid what the hell 87% of people
were completely isolated and only 13%
had an edge incidents though what are
you talking about well what's going on
here is that network of 1,300 workers
those are the quote-unquote super
turkeys if you put a task on Mechanical
Turk they're the ones that you're most
likely to get okay
they're the 20% that do 80% of the work
so it might look like a very sparse
network it's actually
and then if also I was sitting the
audience I would say hey this network
that looks like there's some clusters in
there what's going on with that it turns
out what I've done here is I've colored
the edges according to which online
forum the workers talk on and you know
the magenta at the top is reddit the red
in the bottom right is emptor grind the
orange and the bottom laughter stir
carnation and so on and so forth
so the workers so 90% of all the edges
were between workers who communicate on
one of these online forums so right here
you can see what we did we had this
interview data workers talk to
communicate the collaborate here we
scaled it up now how widespread is it
and then we also did further studies
about what what do they talk about what
media - do they use etcetera etcetera so
there's two takeaways I'd like you to
take from my short presentation
crowdsourcing is less like the top
picture it's less like sampling from a
pool of independent identical workers
and it's more like sampling from a
network and that's the first takeaway
I'd like you to make take and the second
takeaway is there are people here that
study people I am one of them devine is
a former intern of mine if you want to
know what it's like to work with me and
you can talk to him and if you're
interested in any of this send me an
e-mail unfortunately I won't be around
for lunch thank you
[Applause]
you